[Music]
thank you for that generous introduction
what really impresses me about being
alive in the 21st century is how much
kids know when they're 5 years old 10
years old by the time they're 20 they
know things that our predecessors as
much as they might want to know could
not know we're all really blessed with
living in a time when we really are
experiencing their benefits of of the
Giants who preceded us who figured out
how to harness fire who figured out an
alphabet numbers all those things that
we we are the beneficiaries of through
all of human history people learn they
pass it along
people learn they pass it along but
nothing can come close to what's
happening right now
the momentum for learning has taken
course gradual and climbed through all
of human history but never before not
only could we know what is now knowable
but the kids have access to knowledge on
a global scale
you can say that having 7 billion people
on the planet has some problems
associated with it but I think the good
news is we have 7 billion minds that
have access to this weight of knowledge
now it doesn't mean that everybody knows
what isn't there to be known and one
thing I think that we now are beginning
to understand is the magnitude of our
ignorance
of how much more there is not just with
the skies above and we could now know
what our predecessors could not know
it's saying about poor Galileo who was
really given a hard time as a scientist
because he dared to support the idea
that earth is not the center of the
universe oh my what a concept that we're
just one of a whole universe of places
but now we are beginning to suspect that
in all of the universe there's no place
like home the ability to know what no
other creatures on earth can know to see
the consequences of what we're doing I
mean when you look at Earth from high
above looking back it looks a bit like
the reverse for you looking up into the
sky we have altered the perspective that
one has if you go high in the sky and
it's happened literally in the lifetime
of people around I'm one of them I've
been around for long enough to have seen
the changes that are unprecedented not
just with our human society not just
with our scientific discoveries it's
it's we we are changing the nature of
nature through what we do and now we can
see it and know it and measure it and
figure out maybe come closer than ever
before to finding answers to those big
questions who are we where do we come
from
what are we doing at this little blue
speck in the universe changing this
nature of the world so I love the idea
of taking off and let's go to Mars let's
go see what it's like on the red planet
but the idea that it could be a place as
an escape
an alternative to earth some say well
you know we're going to use up the
elements of earth that we need for our
prosperity
so the Mars let's go to Mars let's fix
more so let's make Mars more like Earth
let's terraform Mars but when you think
about it there's a lot we would have to
do to fix Mars to be anything close to
what we already have here and yes Earth
has changed a lot by our actions in our
time in the matter of from the 20th
century on now into the 21st and this
odd thing is while we're trying to
terraform Mars or at least dreaming
about making it more habitable for us
we're Barza forming earth we're putting
more co2 into our atmosphere the
atmosphere of Mars is already mostly
carbon dioxide if you haven't seen that
little film the Martian check it out
you know he was a botanist he was an
engineer or the guy who got stranded on
Mars how are you going to survive
where's the water coming from where's
the oxygen coming from where's the food
coming from Earth is blessed with the
ingredients that are just right for us
and we are a part of a system that goes
back as far as we can tell maybe four
and a half billion years this planet has
been changing naturally you know I you
say just come I say just go temperatures
hotter warmer ocean is more acid and
then it calms down and s'mores has been
for many millions of years holding the
planet steady in our favor but alright
now we know and can reflect on these
things and have a maybe a better idea
not only where we've come from and who
we are but where are we going and maybe
even how are we going to get from where
we are to a better place
armed with knowledge
when I was a kid no one had been up in
space looking back to see earth this
little blue speck in the universe we
might have dreamed of going to Mars but
now we know how tough an assignment that
really is we have just begun to explore
this part of the universe earth I mean
it's right here under our feet this part
of the universe this part of the solar
system
we should go skyward and learn
everything we can using the technologies
that have been developed again it'll
matter mostly building on the giants who
preceded us figuring things out
getting whole systems of Mathematics and
calculations and understanding the
nature of nature but nothing more in
terms of how much we've learned and how
significant it is for our future than in
the last few decades we have learned
more arguably in the last century going
to the technologies that enable us to
not only gather knowledge but to share
knowledge to look at the patterns to
figure things out that we could know
even the smartest people who ever lived
prior to the 20th century could not know
with the kids of today already grow up
with that view of Earth from space
knowledge that Mars is not made of green
cheese as some proposed many years ago
now we know fellow humans have gone high
in the sky recorded information given us
their perspective and instruments
similarly so back in 1970 when those
first footprints were being planted on
the moon some of us were able to take
advantage of the new technologies new at
the time to be able to go in the other
direction to begin to explore this
planet from the inside out there's a
project that NASA was very interested in
so
can people live in isolation for periods
of time underwater is a sort of a
parallel for what might be and what did
become Skylab and then the space station
and dreams maybe of going to Mars so how
do people behave NASA NASA was really
interested you you lock people up for a
couple of weeks or during one year long
program four guys stayed for two full
months in isolation underwater and they
came out good friends unlike some of the
speculation that maybe fewer would come
out than went in so I've had the chance
now to live underwater on ten different
occasions most recently in 2012 it's
really cool what I learned by staying
underwater just as if you go stay in the
forest and go camp in the desert or come
to New York and settle in for a while
you get to know the place you get to
know your neighbors I have enjoyed
sharing the view it was a moment of Zen
on the Jon Stewart Show because I could
while being underwater communicate in
ways that were unthinkable in 1970 let
alone any time prior to that time we
don't have access to parts of our own
home planet in ways that a century ago
were unthinkable to celebrate my
birthday a year and a half ago I got to
dive in the Arctic for the first time so
far the only time I've died within the
Arctic but the idea that you could get
to the Arctic or you could go to
Antarctica this is something that kids
now have as a part of their either
personal or vicarious experience a
knowledge of the world
imagine how limited the horizons were
how limited the knowledge was even a
thousand years ago in the history of the
earth it's just such a tiny piece Oh
of the action I love sharing the view
National Geographic for five years with
a privately supported expedition the
Goldman foundation based in San
Francisco National Geographic and as it
turns out working with NOAA the National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
and we had more than 50 partners in
industry and universities with
individuals nonprofits and commercial
enterprises as well to conduct a program
that we call the sustainable seas
expeditions five years of going around
the coastline of the United States
focusing on areas that were identified
because they had magnified significance
for the ocean breeding areas feeding
areas nursery areas coral reefs seagrass
meadows and we were armed with new
technologies at the time little
one-person submarines that enabled
individuals even scientists so simple to
drive even a scientist could do it and
not just a few of us but there were
about 50 individuals who trained to
pilot these little underwater vehicles
think of down to 2,000 feet I mean
anybody can go to 2,000 feet one way I
mean that's so easy it's the round trips
that really have and to be able to do
something while you're there I really
enjoyed for that five-year period being
able to share the view with kids we had
student summits at the locations that we
rent around the coastline of the United
States looking at areas that either
already have been designated for some
form of protection as marine sanctuaries
like parks in the ocean and to explore
places that needed to be protected
because they have a magnified impact on
the health of the ocean but had not yet
reached that level we went to Mexico on
Belize so we tiptoed a little bit
outside of the US but mainly it was
focused
on let's explore our blue backyard
starting in 1980s this nation of
organizations around the world began
claiming out 200 miles this country is
twice as big is what most people think
of in terms of the area over which we
have jurisdiction now that the exclusive
economic zones have been claimed
so we went out beyond the coastal areas
into some of the blue water parts the
Gulf of Mexico off the coast of
California Hawaii even to [ __ ] OB Bay
and American Samoa so getting kids in a
passenger submarine in Hawaii while we
danced around a little submarines
curiously Hawaii it's an island in the
middle of the Pacific but a lot of those
kids had never been in the water but we
got them in a submarine to be able to
see for themselves what's under the
surface here's the thing from the
surface the ocean today probably looks
much as it did a thousand ten thousand
years ago but below the surface now
we're seeing that there's a lot of
change so fast forward to just last
summer when I had an opportunity to use
a pair of little submarines that were on
board a vessel owned by Ray Dalio
scientists to explore the Gulf of Mexico
it's our backyard it's what some people
call America's ocean where America's
Mediterranean maybe they think in the
better training it was America's Gulf of
Mexico I'm not sure of it anyway lots of
things in common and we had a chance to
explore down to a thousand meters using
these little submarines one of the best
things for me was I had my fingerprints
on one of those little subs I started a
company after I left
NOAA where I served as chief scientist
for a while and began to really
seriously look at how do we solve the
problems
of accessing the sea people can go high
in the sky of it to the moon and send
instruments to Mars but it's amazing how
limited we are in terms of access to the
depths of our own ocean only two people
or two expeditions a total of three
people have been seven miles down to the
deepest part of the ocean go figure how
many how many of you have been seven
miles up in the sky I mean flying a
passenger airplane that's typically
about the height that you flutter that's
what I flew overnight to get here to New
York from San Francisco
seven miles 35,000 feet that's pretty
common millions of people watching
movies taking naps eating lunch but only
three people who have been that far down
into the ocean what are we waiting for
Shh you go high in the sky really
importance of going into the ocean is
now we know or at least it's becoming
clear to a lot of people that the ocean
is the cornerstone of what makes Earth
special all that water 97% of Earth's
water is out there in the ocean and
we're still just nibbling around the top
of the ocean still ignorant about most
of what's out there down there the one
thing we know for sure is that the ocean
is a cornerstone drives climate
temperatures where most of life on Earth
actually lives here said that the ocean
occupies 70% of the Earth's surface well
okay that's the surface but it's
three-dimensional average depth is
two-and-a-half miles maximum 11
kilometers seven miles and it's filled
with life all the way so it's not only
where most of the water is it's where
most of life on Earth is and there's a
census of marine life a 10-year project
they came to a kind of a conclusion but
still continued somewhat in 2012 they
did this
how many of what kinds of creatures live
in the sea the deeper you go the less we
know but the more new discoveries we
find but that seems like a no-brainer
because who's been deep in the ocean not
so many people overall I consider myself
really blessed to be among those who
have had access to the sea I've used
more than 30 different submarines had my
hands on building and I'm not an
engineer but I work with engineers
because as a scientist I really want to
know what's out there so by working with
engineers who can figure out how to
overcome the problems of pressure of
what kinds of cameras what kinds of
lights life support which is one of the
reasons that whether you're an astronaut
in the sky or someone who goes down
beneath the ocean you're really
conscious of things like breathing like
where does air come from likes keep the
temperature within a range that's
suitable so the Gulf of Mexico you know
a lot of headlines I was about oil
spills around the world but especially
at the Gulf of Mexico most particularly
2010 there are natural spills this is
methane being observed by a little deep
sea eel in the Gulf of Mexico methane
naturally bubbling up out of the depths
of the ocean visible because you can see
the bubbles when methane is it exuded
from the earth associated with drilling
and so on you can't see it so you don't
really grasp how much of it's happening
but the bottom of the ocean little
bubbles form it's visible and obviously
that little eel is fascinated you also
see oil coming out natural seeps in the
ocean but in the last half century in
particular since the late 40s and it's
scaling up actually going down but
scaling up the activity drooling in the
deep sea accessing the locked Sun
or bacterial action some of it
chemosynthesis creating oil methane that
we have really tapped into to power our
civilization to new levels of prosperity
we should all be grateful for the
ability to have lights like this and
transportation the clothes we wear so
much the food we eat powered by our
access to the fossil fuels that we have
extracted in recent times but probably
the most important thing in this
valuable thing that fossil fuels have
given us is knowledge is knowledge
insight I mean now we know we can pull
back and see the earth see what's
happening see what we're doing
it's realize this is the time we have to
use our mighty minds to make a change to
its I mean think of this dolphins are so
smart it's so her elephants a lot of
smart birds and I know some really smart
fish but they can do what any kid can do
with any of you can do you look up at
the stars at night and think how
beautiful they are but we know what they
are
dolphin as smart as they are cannot know
what we know we have the power of
knowledge and it's because of all those
who have preceded us who've gathered
knowledge and passed along building
building building and nothing has come
close to the acceleration of knowledge
that has happened not just in the last
century the last half-century and the
rate is picking up and maybe the most
important thing that we can do right now
armed with knowledge is to get back to
that question who are we where did we
come from and if we really want a long
and enduring future how are we going to
get there
not by doing what we've been doing in
terms of looking at this beautiful blue
speck in the
and consuming it consuming consuming the
birds the water the air the mammals on
the land the trees fish in the sea it
used to be well when our numbers were
small you could do that and get away
with it you you level this first and
then you move on to the next one you
catch fish in this area and then you
move on to the next place and it's been
that way through all of our existence
until right about now now we know we can
see the world and see the limits I heard
President Obama say once our highest
priority must be to keep the world safe
for her children he was thinking guns
and things but think about the comment
our highest priority must be to keep the
world safe for our children well we know
that keeping the world safe keeping the
natural world safe the systems that
generate oxygen our life-support system
capture carbon hold the planet steady to
keep within a certain favourable
temperature for humans now that we can
see armed with knowledge of the past a
view of the present what we do again the
idea of taking kids only this time on a
journey around the coastline of this
country at least and ultimately thinking
about the world to take them underwater
we took a few kids a team of people Bob
Nixon who produced the film called Sea
of Hope and Sarah Nixon and their kids a
couple of my grandkids and my kids were
involved but we also got some youngsters
teenagers from the part of Washington DC
that is not as well off as some other
parts of Washington DC a couple of kids
who'd never seen the ocean never been on
a boat never been course they hadn't
been in the ocean if they hadn't seen it
never been on an airplane and certainly
had not been in the submarine but we did
all those things
to give them a view of what is now
possible and to turn them loose so just
a few little glimpses and see of hope
[Music]
[Music]
so it's a National Geographic film
that's been now spread all over the
world I hope you can see it if you have
not already what it does is just try to
convey the urgency of taking care of the
planet that takes care of us now we know
so slide back again 1979 I had a chance
to use this piece of equipment again it
was a National Geographic project to
look at the ocean floor of Hawaii armed
with a walking suit looks like a
refrigerator or some people were
generous since it looks like an
astronaut suit similar to an astronaut
suit in that your rebreathing the air
that was contained so I was able to
spend hours walking around at twelve
hundred and fifty feet beneath the
surface well holding my breath I
couldn't get there even using scuba I
can't get there even using modern
rebreathers I could not get there but
with this suit I was able to stay and
get acquainted with some wonderful
organisms that live on the bottom of the
ocean that you can get to know if you
drag a net across the bottom and bring
up to the surface but you cannot see how
they live or what they do so we went
back to the same place of Hawaii last
year using the Pisces subs the
University of Hawaii has two 2000 meter
submersibles and we took the kids along
and more than that I had a chance to see
Carl's that I had seen back in 1979 and
the wonderful thing is when you turn out
the lights and you touch these Carl's
they glow a pulse-width blue fire
bioluminescence like Firefly light only
in the ocean it's common I mean 90% or
so of creatures in the deep sea can make
some form of light from bacteria up to
Carl's and fish that cultivate bacteria
under their eyes or in little spots down
their side squids that squirt out
bioluminescent ink it's mostly a dark
cold deep high-pressure world but there
is light you just have to
you know what to look for and get there
and see it but I could not do more than
just describe it could not take a
photograph of it back in 1979 but fast
forward to last summer with the kids
arming the cameras new Canon camera with
4 million ISO now if your photographer
you can appreciate whoa you can take
pictures in the dark and we really did
take pictures in the dark we were able
to actually grab images of the light as
it was being manufactured by living like
these Carl's so him for me living
through this remarkable time of
technology that enables us to do things
see things understand things that even
our immediate predecessors could only
dream about we are the luckiest people
ever ever to live on earth because not
only is it not too late to turn things
around armed with what we now know in
terms of protecting the coral reefs
protecting seagrass Meadows protecting
mangroves they're not all gone we still
have ten percent of the sharks in the
ocean from when I was a kid which was a
while ago but not that long ago
geologically speaking and tunas bluefin
tuna that's so treasured in restaurants
around the world sushi and sashimi or
tuna steak blue fins when I was chief
scientists at NOAA the figures were well
it looks like maybe maybe ninety percent
are gone in the North Atlantic well if
the news has gotten worse
so in around the world yeah tunas here's
where they were in the middle of the
20th century here's where they are why
because we've developed a taste for them
and we think that their renewable
resource well maybe they are but we
certainly aren't fishing in a way that
you could call renewable win and a few
decades you can go from here to here I
mean what are we thinking
so what we're thinking is we need to no
need to explore need to harness the
technologies that now exist to give us
the knowledge that we need to manage our
life-support system we will use trees we
will eat fish we will breathe the air
but there are limits to how much we can
undercut our life-support system and
still have a planet that works in her
favor that's the big news of the 21st
century that we now have a chance to do
something about it so Jim Cameron who's
a filmmaker a storyteller but also a
scientist also deep in his heart of
hearts he's an engineer he solves
problems he builds things including a
craft that took him all by himself
solo James Cameron film director
Explorer Explorer in residence at the
National Geographic actually to the
deepest part of the ocean and he came
back whoo-hoo a little piece of
California what with him the manipulator
arm was built by the company that I
started but my daughter and son-in-law
own and operate and are pushing to try
to get the new technologies democratized
so that any of you if you want to go off
to explore seven miles down why should
you not be able to do so huh anyway
Hertz Rena sub or Avis or whatever we we
need to amp it up as I began exploring
the ocean I was warned about sharks you
know creatures that could eat they say
eat you look out because they're
man-eaters out there and then I stopped
worrying because I'm don't qualify as a
man and so but the thing is we are doing
a great job of consuming them well we
worry about them consuming us all these
thoughts about the big teeth my dentist
has a copy of this picture and hanging
in his office
but the kind of teeth we have to worry
about these days teeth on deep-sea
mining equipment accessing parts of the
planet for the first time that we've not
been to yet areas that are like 20,000
feet beneath the surface of the ocean a
sense of submarine life the deeper you
go the less we know are the more new
discoveries we make but it's not too
deep for exploitation we're so good at
exploiting the planet but we now know
that we have to be really careful about
doing that and as we explore to
understand the real value yes you can
think in terms of pounds of meat when
you think of whales where you can think
of of minerals in the deep sea but what
about the communities of life that are
sacrificed in the process of the mining
activities questions that we could not
answer could I ask didn't know enough to
ask even 20 years ago so new
technologies they're there to be done I
love talking to kids and see who has
that spark of an engineer or an explorer
or scientist or a poet a storyteller
whatever to be able to use their talents
to get out there and do things curiously
even though most of the ocean may be 90
plus percent of the ocean has never been
seen by anybody our mark is there this
picture was taken in the Mariana Trench
the deepest part of the ocean
so we're there we just don't have the
information back for most of the planet
new tools are coming along I love these
pieces of equipment new little
submarines they're coming along more and
more available so you can rent a
submarine in some cases but we still
need to do what was done and for
aviation early in the 20th century now
early in the 21st to be able to explore
the world
and go to places that we have have been
identified as critical to the health of
the ocean the health of the planet our
health our security everything we care
about life itself depends on kind of
holding the planet steady so over the
last few years
places identified as Hope spots some
have identified marine reserves
sanctuaries whatever you want to call
them but to look at the ocean to figure
out what can we not afford to lose what
do we have to hold in place to hold the
planet steady to keep the world safe of
course for our children but how about us
as well right now going to the Arctic
going to Antarctica once a really big
deal now getting to Antarctica is
accessible if you can afford to buy a
ticket on a cruise ship you can go down
and see the frozen bottom of the world
or to shift gears and go to the top of
the world and to be a witness yes I have
been a witness as all of you are but to
really focus on what are we learning and
what are we losing and how far can we go
in terms of consuming the natural world
that keeps us alive isn't it time that
we give back to take care of the vital
parts of the planet take care of us
imagine if going back to early in the
20th century no one had taken measures
to actually protect national parks
imagine if we had to start today from
scratch what places would be left if no
one going back to the early part of the
20th century it taken measures to secure
safe havens for wildlife for water for
that which keeps the air healthy so
we're
right on the edge now with the ocean it
took as ed Wilson who was honored by the
world science festival on his 80th
birthday here in New York
he said we consumed the large the slow
and the tasty from the land it took ten
thousand years the ocean is taking us a
few decades to remove from the ocean and
bring close to extinction and in some
cases over the edge so that they're just
gone I can forgive those a thousand
years ago or even five hundred years ago
even fifty years ago they did not
understand the nature of the impact that
we're having on the ocean and the
creatures who live not just in the ocean
but on the planet as a whole
but there's no excuse anymore
the knowledge is there about our ability
to not only lose much of the natural
world but why it matters why the ocean
matters why wills matter for more than
pounds of meat barrels of oil it wasn't
that long ago that that is how whales
were regarded and we just did not think
about whales in other ways and I don't
mean just the economic value of whale
watching although that's a pretty big
deal these days worth much more whales
alive for tourism than whales dead for
products but it's more than that it's
more than that as nature is is our
life-support system and whales are part
of it birds are part of it trees are a
part of it fish are a part of it
microbes are certainly a big part of our
life-support system we need to think of
wills with other values sure we can kill
them and sell them off and then they're
gone they came perilously close to the
point of no return for many kinds of
whales and for some maybe we we
have achieved the point of no return no
return for northern right wheels bowhead
whales their numbers you know every year
you take a census and you say well are
the births this year exceeding the
deaths you know you get to that point
where you get on this runaway
period of decline happened with
passenger pigeons there's still
thousands of them but they're already on
the way out it's happening perhaps with
whales certainly happening with this
little dolphin that lives in Mexico it's
called the vaquita it's a victim of
fishing it's not targeted specifically
for taking but it's being caught in
fishermen's nets and what are they after
they're after a fish that tastes good
but not really after it to eat they're
after it for the swim bladder that can
be sold in Chinese markets for big bucks
one swim bladder just a few weeks ago
ago reportedly sold for a hundred and
seventy five thousand dollars so you
almost can't afford to leave these fish
alive in the ocean if somebody's going
to pay that much just for this buoyancy
compensator system that many fish have
within them but this one this total has
become prayut priced priced in Asian
markets for more mysterious reasons like
rhinoceros horn why but in the process
those little dolphins the vaquita the
last census taken a few weeks ago
suggest they're only 33 zero left they
are probably going to go the way of the
dodo we did not know if that wasn't
years ago or a few hundred years ago and
Dodos were exterminated
we thought there always be another place
where they live or even if they go
extinct so what people say that Mouse
but what if we lose elephants so what if
the vaquita goes extinct so what why
should I care
knowing how everything connects gives us
the insight for the first time I think
in all of human history to be able to
give an answer to those questions it's
like okay here's your computer what's
this little thing over here if I take it
out
the computer goes wonky and put it back
in oh now it's working again or it takes
something out here
there we have taken pieces out of this
amazing system unique in the universe
deliberately in some cases mindfully but
now we know that it matters what we take
matters what we do to the systems that
keep us alive
so fishing is now at a point in history
about where whaling was early in the
20th century we don't think of fish as
wildlife we think of them as products we
think of them as tons of things not not
someone it's not not individuals we talk
about tons of tuna the way you used to
talk about tons of whales but it's
changing as we begin to explore the
ocean and see the value of life in the
ocean beyond just products thing is you
go diving in the ocean or exploring the
ocean today you see more than just fish
and microbes you see a lot of our trash
that didn't exist plastics did not exist
when I began exploring the ocean in the
1950s just did not exist now some say
that by the middle of this century there
may be more bits of plastic in the ocean
than there are fish well who knows
probably may not be an exaggeration if
we keep taking out millions of tons of
fish and putting into the ocean millions
of tons of our trash could be the way
things are going to turn out so choices
here we are the best time in all of
human history to be alive we're learning
from those who preceded us we don't have
to start from scratch we've the
beneficiaries of all of this insight all
of this science all of this evidence
we have a better chance than any who've
ever lived because we still have whales
we still have tunas we still have sharks
I was diving with some last week out at
Cocos Island and cause for hope because
that area has been protected now for
about 20 years when I first went there
in 1972 oh my gosh
the place was a shark gayest place I'd
ever known shark eating one of the
sketchiest places on the planet and then
there was a time when fishing for their
fins and for the meat and so on took
their numbers damn now cause for hope
with protection from Costa Rica they are
recovering but there's still an appetite
for shark fin soup there's still an
appetite for even the biggest fish in
the sea a whale shark and their big fins
but we're getting better knowledge is
getting distributed we have the capacity
to learn there's more to a fish than
something on a plate with lemon slices
and butter fish have faces fish have
families personalities they do care for
the young in different ways I mean
depends on this wide range of 33000
kinds of creatures we call fish and yet
you can go to a menu in a restaurant and
they'll say you can have chicken or you
can have beef or you can have lamb or
you can have fish fish which what kind
of fish and maybe you'll get an answer
that fish chowder or fish and chips is
think they might know what it is that
often you don't just eating a product
but now that it's knowable the nature of
what is out in the sea and fish have
faces for heaven's sakes if they could
speak if fish could vote we'd probably
have some different walls every fish
like every human like every cat every
dog whatever we're all different DNA
every one of those fish
is unique like fingerprints we know
these things now so why aren't we acting
on that knowledge when a new technique
new technology enabled scientists from
MIT on a cruise and what looked like
clear ocean water in off Bermuda
discovered prochlorococcus it's a word
you should hold close to your heart
because about 20% of the oxygen in the
atmosphere is generated by
prochlorococcus imagine we didn't know
it existed until the 1980s here's the
thing there Bluegreen bacteria they
generate oxygen take up carbon drive
help drive the great ocean food webs
along with other marine bacteria other
marine microbes other marine
phytoplankton and zooplankton we are
beginning to understand that we're not
the big boss of the world after all
these guys the little guys rule they
have been around long before there are
creatures with backbones
brains and all of that they have helped
shape the world into a place that's
suitable for us food chains in the ocean
largely driven by these minut organisms
and they will respect trees and we
should the forests on the land for
generating oxygen producing food and
shelter and the many things but in ocean
the big drivers start very small and
they go up through the food web little
crustaceans are eaten by small fish
eaten by bigger fish and so on and here
in action is a food chain in the ocean
the great thing about this is observing
it documenting it but not becoming a
part of it so you can't see the
prochlorococcus or that Cocola thefor
heads or the diatoms or the other my new
engines that start capturing sunlight
generating oxygen capturing carbon but
there it is and every element along the
way captures carbon passes it along
and from the tiniest little copepod to
the biggest shark or the biggest whale
they process the nutrients and they put
nutrients back yeah as they say whales
poop and so the tunas and you know what
fish do in the ocean well it's a big
nutrient cycle changing its the
chemistry of the planet in action and we
could not even imagine knowing such
things when I was a kid but now we know
but the one thing that I could not
imagine as a kid was that we could
change the nature of the planet as a
whole
altered the oxygen in the atmosphere
alter the carbon cycle the nitrogen
cycle the water cycle changed the
climate of the planet it was
inconceivable but now we know and here's
the thing the kids know too
I want to show you just another little
clip from sea of hope it's look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's what we have riding around on our
shoulders the capacity to observe
carefully report honestly act on what we
know and make better decisions about our
future
coral reefs about half around the world
are already gone or are in a state of
sharp decline why we know why if we have
the evidence it's global warming
well where did that come from now we
know we've got the evidence we're
putting up into the sky is having an
impact on polar ice sea level rise
acidification of the ocean is a excess
carbon dioxide goes beyond what the
ocean can absorb turns to carbonic acid
and we're seeing a rapid acceleration of
chemistry
changes in the ocean partly because of
what we're putting in but also because
of what we're taking out I mean millions
of tons of this these living systems
extracted from the ocean every one
carbon-based unit changing the nature of
the ocean alright cause for hope lots of
reasons good reasons so in the latter
days of the administration of George W
Bush probably largely because of Laura
who had a thing about national parks and
a champion for nature went to Midway
Island site of World War two conflict
but it's been protected by a number of
presidents over the years starting with
President Teddy Roosevelt on the land
the island the birds but the ocean has
until fairly recently been largely
neglected but President Bush did
something remarkable established the
largest marine protected area on the
planet with a stroke of his pen using
the antiquities act that most presidents
have used at one time or another to
protect
the natural cultural or historic
heritage valuable for this country but
for the world so fast forward to last
summer and there was President Obama
building on that legacy and expanding
that monumental monument of who will to
make it at the time as of last September
the largest marine protected area you
know cause for hope it's a safe haven in
the middle of this vast ocean one of
those places that has a magnified impact
on holding the planet steady sources of
restoration for depleted species whether
it's a whale monk seal heart a tuna fish
a few weeks later remarkably nations
around the world came together and upped
the ante from the time that President
Bush started the momentum in a serious
way maybe because it was President Bush
maybe it's because the largest or
whatever it was
nations around the world began to say
mmm maybe the ocean has been sending a
message coral reefs are declining sea
levels rising the ocean is warming the
ocean is acidifying we are looking at
change of the chemistry of the ocean
what could we do well one thing you can
do is just as we did for the land if you
want to have birds protect the places
they live if you want to have clean
water protect the water systems protect
the rivers in the ocean similarly let's
make some action to protect the nature
of nature and so in the Ross Sea in
Antarctica at just the 2016 the biggest
marine protected area on earth but it
sounds great and it is great but here's
the ocean here's how much is protected
if you put all the protection together
in one big blue pile we're still looking
it depends on which measure you use is
it got some form of management or is it
fully protected we're even the fish and
the lobsters and the shrimp and the
phytoplankton and you name it
have some proactive not just by the fact
that they're inaccessible or we haven't
gotten there yet but proactively
protected it's right about three percent
so if you think of the ocean as the blue
heart of the planet the blue heart holds
the planet steady it's three percent of
your heart enough is Ed Wilson on the
right track when he says you know mighty
ed Wilson Harvard University the famous
ant-man but he has a new book called
half earth that we need he says done
some pretty convincing scientific
evidence based calculations that we go
flat out right now and provide safe
havens on the land and in the sea for
half the earth gives us a fighting
chance to hold the planet steady and
ensure an enduring place for ourselves
within the natural systems they give us
everything whether its economy or health
or security but mostly existence most
important thing that we take from the
ocean or from nature is our existence no
we know birds cannot know this
I met this bird the last picture I'm
going to show you in 2012
turns out she was learning to fly she's
a Laysan albatross live a long time like
some humans Laysan albatrosses tend to
make for life so she was sitting on her
most recent egg when I met her but she
was learning to fly about the same time
that I was learning to dive in the 1950s
and there we were I just tried to
imagine what she's seen in the ocean
during her lifetime for sure fewer squid
for sure
fewer little fish for sure plastics that
didn't exist she may look at the stars
and printer what they are I on the other
hand like the bird has been given the
name wisdom we both witnessed change but
I know why the changes are taking place
and I know why it matters and I know
that they're things my species can do
there'll be a benefit to her and all of
her kind and all the rest of life on
earth including us she cannot know these
things as smart as she is as smart as
the people who preceded us have been
they could not see what we now can see
which is the great good news armed with
knowledge we have a chance plenty of
reason for hope
thank you for coming
[Applause]
[Music]